this video is brought to you by better
help
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about my two favorite things in the
world after tick tock videos of aussie
shepherd puppies of course that's right
philosophy and art what can i say i was
educated in the finest florida public
schools and there's an intersection
between the two that's been all over the
media lately should art and
entertainment be moral or ethical it
feels like recently media criticism has
become super focused on the supposed
morality or lack thereof of popular
films tv books and so on this all led
writer and critic wesley morris to
declare that culture is being evaluated
for its moral correctness more than for
its quality we've seen this exemplified
in the media reaction to say joker which
many were convinced would persuade
people to dress up like sad clowns land
a guest spot on a talk show and shoot
the talk show host who they also have
weird daddy fantasies about or as
heather anne campbell tweeted can't
believe the end of joker is walking
phoenix turning to camera and saying now
you do joker stuff in contrast adam
mckay's don't look up was widely
applauded but generally more so for its
moral appeal that we should you know
save the dying rock we live on
rather than for its actual artistic
merit this led many to bristle at the
implication that if you don't like the
movie you don't care about climate
change all of this has us wondering does
good art need to be moral and when our
culture debates the morality of art are
we asking the right questions let's dive
into this totally not contentious issue
in this wisecrack edition should art be
moral note this is a different question
from should we stop consuming art made
by a moral artist so we won't be
discussing whether or not you can still
listen to i believe i can fly but before
we get into it we want to thank this
video sponsor better help are you
dealing with something that's preventing
you from achieving your goals or that's
interfering with your happiness no
matter what's wrong and no matter where
you live betterhelp can assess your
needs and pair you with your own
licensed professional therapist thanks
to betterhelp's network of more than 20
000 therapists it's easy to find the one
whose expertise fits your specific needs
that said it's easy and free to switch
if you aren't a match once you're
registered for better help you can start
communicating with your therapist within
48 hours whenever you send a message to
your therapist you're sure to receive a
thoughtful and timely response plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions too now a better help is not a
crisis line and it is not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online plus it's more affordable than
in-person therapy and financial aid is
available better help is invested in
your journey toward a happier life so
visit betterhealth.com
wisecrack to join the over 2 million
people who have already taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional and when you go
to betterhealth.com wisecrack you'll get
10 percent off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
wisecrack and now back to the show now
philosophers critics and artists have
been debating the tension between art
and morality since ancient greek times
what's more cultural handwringing about
immoral art turning us all into
unprincipled hooligans is nothing new
for much of history art has actually
been heavily controlled by each era's
moral authorities during the middle ages
in europe painters saw aesthetics
crushed by what scholar fb chambers
calls the christian moral resistance
like the infamous bonfire of the
vanities in 1497 where an incensed
fanatical italian monk convinced mobs to
burn everything he found heretical from
books to artwork to musical instruments
even makeup it's theorized that famous
painter botticelli was even persuaded to
burn some of his own paintings that were
considered heretical in the renaissance
things changed a bit painters like
leonardo da vinci defined their artistic
duty as uniting aesthetics and morality
into beautiful moral art but the
enlightenment changed everything the
free thinking more secular era saw
european artists largely emancipated
from moral policing what followed as
scholar arnold berlant writes was an
aberration in arts history as artists
finally became basically autonomous of
course this freedom left some
disgruntled and over the centuries has
led to artists like d.h lawrence being
taken to court over their arts supposed
immorality though his publisher penguin
books was the one on trial and we can
only hope mr penguin was forced to take
the stand critiques of a moral art have
continued into the modern day typically
surfacing as moral panics over the art
children are consuming rock and roll was
going to turn the teens into sex
monsters in the 50s and the 80s and 90s
saw major hysteria about violence in rap
video games action movies and so on
surely kids were being prepped for lives
of crime of course crime rates plummeted
straight up plummeted in the 90s but
while that facts get in the way of a
good old-fashioned moral panic at the
same time there's been a recent
reckoning with some of history's more
questionable works of art take birth of
a nation which was once hailed as an
astonishing feat of early american
filmmaking today it is better known for
almost single-handedly reviving the kkk
and today the tension between art and
morality lingers artists aren't being
explicitly policed by say the church at
the same time they are subject to an
increasingly loud court of public
opinion that especially on social media
is often quite critical of art's
perceived moral shortcomings take the
loki hysterics surrounding the release
of the hunt which reimagined america's
political divide as hide and seek but
had shotguns with all this we think the
real overarching question when it comes
to ethical criticism of art is does the
implied ethics of a work of art affect
its aesthetic value scholar noel carroll
characterized the two main opposing
sides in the debate as such on one side
there's autonomism this is the view that
as carroll writes art and ethics are
autonomous realms of value and thus
criteria from the ethical realm should
not be imported to evaluate the
aesthetic realm this is also called
aestheticism and its inherents argue
that art should be considered valuable
for its aesthetic qualities not for its
ability to morally enlighten or improve
us as proponent oscar wilde put it there
is no such thing as a moral or an
immoral book books are well written or
badly written that is all more commonly
moderate autonomism holds that it's
possible to morally evaluate art but
it's just not relevant to whether that
art is actually good or bad
aesthetically speaking on the other side
there's moralism this is the view that
if a work of art has immoral
implications those implications
contribute to its aesthetic defects
therefore the aesthetic value of art can
be compromised by its immorality now
let's take a closer look at each side
autonomism has quite a philosophical
history the likes of human kant believe
that we have to separate aesthetic and
moral faculties philosopher francis
hutchison considered those faculties
distinctive enough to be considered like
different senses as in hearing versus
seeing just like you can't use your ears
to evaluate the crumb on this week's
bake off you can't use your moral
compass to evaluate art kant believed
that what we consider pleasurable
aesthetically is our taste and what we
consider pleasurable morally is simply
our moral feeling in more recent years
scholar clive bell has argued that art
or at least visual art needs to satisfy
two essential features it provokes a
particular sort of emotional response
and that emotional response is the
proper basis of its aesthetic evaluation
once we've judged something as art he
argued morality becomes about as
relevant as a piano is to a pig he notes
that as art is above morals or rather
all art is moral because works of art
are immediate means to good once we have
judged a thing a work of art we have
judged it ethically of the first
importance and put it beyond the reach
of the moralist under this view you
could judge joker as a work of art for
engendering the emotions of say
fear anxiety or coulrophobia i.e fear of
clowns that go bump in the night this
seems fair thus joker's moral message is
rendered irrelevant and the work is
beyond ethical reproach as bell puts it
we should liberate the artist from moral
judgment then there's moralism which is
dominated for most of human history
carol notes that before the wedge was
driven between ethics and aesthetics by
hutchison and kant ethical criticism of
art was common and thought of as totally
appropriate prominently there was
plato's criticism of music and poetry in
republic which he believed was making
kids naughty his argument culminates
with socrates saying that poets
including mother effin homer would be
banned from the ideal city in the late
19th century leo tolstoy leaned into
moralism rejecting aesthetic theories
that focused on beauty he complained
that upper class european art got bad
when it stopped being religious and
fretted that the resulting art directly
corrupts people by infecting them with
the worst and humanly most harmful
feelings chiefly of sensuality and he
never even lived to reach 50 shades of
grey he draws an analogy with food
people may eat food for pleasure but its
real function is nourishment likewise
people may consume art for pleasure but
its real function is to communicate
specifically to communicate emotions the
more the art infects you with those
emotions the better the art is so long
as those emotions are
the ones valued by tolstoy's humanist
brand of christianity deep religious
feeling horror and injustice and so on
moral virtue and artistic virtue become
one and the same some moralists point to
art that is
pretty objectively morally troubling to
support their argument triumph of the
will is a common example made by the
nazi state's favorite director lenny
riefenstahl the movie unabashedly
worships hitler and his ideology it is
at the same time an aesthetically
creative and groundbreaking work of
cinema but more or less argue that any
aesthetic achievements are sullied by
the film's objectively deep world view
now nobody wants to be the guy who
argues in favor of triumph of the will
but at first blush
we do feel like the autonomous make a
good point after all didactic art with a
moral worldview can have little
aesthetic value take something like the
blindside which takes the morally
correct stance on the question of should
we be racist while at the same time
offering very little in the realm of
aesthetics what's more lots of good
abstract art has plenty of aesthetic
value but has no objective moral value
carol calls the argument regarding
abstract art the common denominator
argument and he finds it the most
persuasive of the autonomous basically
we must be able to apply our criterion
for evaluating art to all kinds of art
but as he explains since it is the case
that much art does not concern morality
directly ethics cannot be the
appropriate criterion for evaluating art
if you can't apply moral judgment to
every piece of art that is why should
you apply it to any that said we see the
moralist point when it comes to things
like triumph of the will or birth of the
nation so we're left pretty torn but
before you despair there's one viewpoint
that offers a life-saving curveball and
was given by writer and philosopher iris
murdoch for murdock the function of the
best art is to pierce the veil and let
us see things as they truly are
but for her this vision is inseparable
from virtue and to convey a truthful
vision of the world the artist needs to
understand human virtue truth then
becomes the real morality murdoch
believed that the best art holds up a
mirror to reality including and in
particular moral reality but if an
artist wants us to better understand
reality and morality they need to
understand it in the first place under
this thinking triumph of the will and
birth of the nation can't possibly be
considered great works of art because
they don't show a true picture of the
world they're both functionally racist
fever dreams philosopher ah hannah takes
it one step further arguing that art can
even push a society's morality forward
art is then seen throughout history to
be continually helping in the creation
of new values in the trans valuation of
values like how get out can make us
think about the way white liberals
contribute to systematic racism or how
parasite can make us rethink inequality
or how first reformed reframes the
environmental justice movement to ask
should a drunk horny priest blow up his
church now without committing to
moralism let's entertain the notion that
the ethical content of a work is
directly relevant to its value as art if
that's true it's natural to ask whether
a piece of art could help us see the
world more clearly by openly depicting
immoral content some widely acclaimed
films about war and organized crime
might fit the bill or 90s rap that gave
us an unflinching picture of what life
was like in places like queens or
compton it's hard to imagine how
illmatic could have been improved by a
cleaner more unproblematic moral stance
or that the godfather would have been
better art if nobody had played pranks
with horse heads
philosopher jon stewart mill said that
he who knows only his own side of the
case knows little of that his reasons
may be good and no one may have been
able to refute them but if he is equally
unable to refute the reasons on the
opposite side if he does not so much as
know what they are he has no ground for
preferring either opinion that is to say
if we only see our characters doing
moral things we never get to experience
immorality in art and we can't truly
call ourselves fully morally engaged
that means there could be value in art
that represents immoral activities if
and only if it shows us a true
perspective on the world as laid out by
iris murdoch and if it's a novel one all
the better right of course this is not
without complication for example the
film scarface is for many a parable
about how you shouldn't solve arguments
with machine guns but for some of the
rappers featured on mtv cribs in the
early aughts it's an aspirational tale
what are we to make of that the honest
answer might be that as an artist
depicting morally questionable behavior
you do not and cannot have total control
over how people interpret your work
what's more morality can be relative
thus what does and does not constitute
immoral art can be
fluid and that makes the task of morally
evaluating these works murky at best
however because immorality does exist in
the world portraying it truthfully could
paradoxically be a moral thing to do and
what's more
works that intentionally or not display
immorality can also be highly useful to
engage with even if they only reveal our
own shortcomings and we think evaluating
the immoral virtue of art is perhaps the
crux of this media conflict people who
criticize joker don't typically believe
that the film is endorsing the joker's
actions they believe that the very
depiction of those actions is dangerous
but if joker shows wild clown antics for
the purpose of say commenting on the
scourge that is america's underfunded
mental health care system then could its
immorality have a moral purpose to go
back to wesley morris when we expect all
of our art to be morally upstanding
there's a real consequence he writes we
wind up with safer art and discourse
that provokes and disturbs and shocks
less it gives us culture whose artistic
value has been replaced by moral
judgment and leaves us with
mono-criticism so maybe the real answer
is that yes art should be moral but its
main moral obligation is to be truthful
about the world in which case art that
shows the world's immorality truthfully
is a bit ironically
in terms of morality but what do you
guys think are the autonomous right that
ethics has no role to play in evaluating
art are moralists like tolstoy right
that immoral art makes us hedonos is
morality and art really just truth and
if so can immoral art actually be
totally moral let us know what you think
in the comments big thanks to our
patrons for all your support and be sure
to stop by our updated patreon page and
don't forget to check us out on tick
tock clutch that subscribe button like
it's tip tipper gore string of pearls
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]